Branches happen on a single repository.
Of course, you can push and pull branches, but when you create one,
you're creating it on one single repository, so
the only one that could possibly fit that mold is this one.
We have one branch and here we've got a second branch.
So this one is a branch.
Cloning involves taking an existing repository and making one just like it.
The original repository could either be remote, like in this case, so
here we cloned from GitHub to local.
Or you could even clone a local repository into another spot on your computer.
We haven't really talked about this, so this one was probably a little tricky.
This one looks a lot like a clone too, but
remember, we are cloning our repository from GitHub onto GitHub.
You do that using GitHub's built-in fork feature.
Forking is only used within the context of GitHub, taking an existing GitHub
repository and making a copy of it, whereas clone works on any two repositories.